well next uh one american sheriff's
crusade against school shootings sheriff
carmine marcino of lee county florida
believes that shaming offenders however
young is a powerful deterrent his
detectives purp walked a 10 year old who
sent a text message joking he was
planning to attack his school
he's also published among shots of at
least eight other miners arrested for
serious offenses
well i'm joined now by sheriff carmine
martinez sheriff thank you very much for
joining me
some people will say
this is great others will say this seems
ludicrously tough love
for kids of this age
um how do you justify what you've been
doing
you know for me it's really safe uh to
say that look safe kids safe school is
my top priority uh and i have to do
what's right at the end of the day and
people want transparency so i have
countless parents and countless other
guardians that text and call me and
email me to say thank you you know
pierce i know that you have a young
loved one obviously you have a daughter
uh so so it hits home with you as well i
mean i ask you how do you feel when you
drop your child off today you got to be
worried as a parent or a guardian and
you want someone that's going to take a
zero tolerance stance and let me ask you
this pierce your child is i believe 10
years old give or take you have a
daughter okay that's your most precious
gift in life if someone in that child's
classroom was written or writing a
threat or committing uh a wanted to
commit mass shooting would you want to
know who that is listen i i i i actually
agree with what you're doing i i know
it's hard i know it's tough but i also
think it's completely outrageous if kids
have 10 you know they're
they're old enough at ten to know they
shouldn't be doing what this kid in
particular was doing and following a
school shooting threatening to shoot up
a school is just completely outrageous
and actually i do think a bit of a short
sharp shock can be effective is my
honest response to it so you know also i
i want the parents and guardians to help
me help me be successful sit your
children down and talk about things and
also i mean the last thing we want to do
the last thing is put a 10 year old in
handcuffs i don't want to talk about
school shootings this is not a political
issue for me it's a safety and security
issue and i have to do what's right
every time
if i don't okay i have to sleep at night
and god forbid we leave no stone
unturned and every threat is real and i
got to make sure that one of those
hundred thousand kids that go to school
if there's a threat that nothing waits
one second we're going to engage that
threat immediately and that's the only
way
matthew mcconaughey has been at the
white house today he comes from a valley
in texas where this school shooting
happened been very passionate about the
need for america to do something that it
can't just respond the way it did after
sandy hook by having a lot of arguments
and then nothing being done what do you
think it's the solution to what has been
going on with these mass shootings
says a few things first and foremost
america has to wake up okay don't ignore
red flags you really want to focus on
stopping these shootings okay guns are
not the issue what's the issue is people
ignoring red flags when you talk about
texas there's a shooter okay who writes
online children being fear of your lives
for real okay he tells people about
things and those people don't come
forward you know what charge those
people that's on them when someone as a
good human being you need to come
forward and let people know when you
know that something's going down or if
there's a threat of violence come
forward okay it's your constitutional
right to have to have arms yes there are
lots of issues here i i think mental
health is a big problem the red flags
are a huge problem as you said it uh i
think violent video games shouldn't be
disregarded this lady shooter was
obsessed with call of duty i think if
you play that kind of game for too long
and you are disturbed it can make you
know real life seem blurry to you but
when you say it's not about the guns
what we would say here
uh in the uk and i accept we're not
american citizens this is for you to
work out as a country but obviously guns
play a part too because if these
deranged young kids don't have ready
access to semi-automatic rifles they
can't do what this person did and the
argument i hear all the time is well if
you take any guns away the criminals
will still get them but you can apply
that logic as you know as a sheriff to
any law frankly
so so i agree with you first of all many
different things mental health is a huge
huge part of this secondly okay i do
agree that bad people will always have
guns so the more good people you arm
okay the only thing you can do with
lethal force and stopping it is to
create lethal force or deadly force
against it you can't kill evil enough
let's look at the gun the gun states
that don't want guns like my hometown in
new york chicago we have record
shootings and murders and those are the
ones where you can't have guns the same
way you can in all great state of
florida so when you look at places like
chicago and new york okay 20 shootings
in a weekend
well i mean i get what does that mean
does it mean that well you have strict
gun laws but yet we have 20 shootings
that's unacceptable and people have to
defend you know in your household you
are the first responder okay we respond
as law enforcement but you are the first
responder and you have to make certain
that you and your family are protected
and when someone presents deadly force
in one of my schools 118
100 000 kids if a suspect makes a
decision on that person to bring deadly
force to my school they're going to be
met with deadly force in not one second
and we are going to kill them with no
questions sheriff uh it's an interesting
debate because i've had this for many
years and the reality is when we gave up
a lot of civilian gun ownership in the
uk
we didn't have a big culture of gun
ownership to start with that's the
reality in america there are 400 million
guns in circulation 45 of homes have
guns in the homes it is much more
complicated and i understand that but i
appreciate you joining me and keep up
the good work
pierce thank you so much